hey everybody i'm back uh the the stream
did completely died
the stream completely died and uh my
graphics are all weird i was able to get
res i restarted as soon as possible i
don't have all my elements going
my computer it went blue screen it's
never happened ever
during a uh during a live stream before
but
we are we are we are back live and um
standing by here
for donald trump being transported to
walter reed
and uh we'll have more i'll slowly get
all of the elements of the stream
restarted
i did not leave or anything like that um
let's just listen to what's being said
on nbc
uh as i get all of the the stream things
set back up it usually does take me like
15 minutes so i'm going to see if i can
get everything going here
because some presidents have shied away
from
giving power to a vice president because
they think it shows weakness
and that is especially true during a
presidential re-election campaign
lester we have never seen anything like
the scene that we were about to see
a president being taken from the white
house to a
hospital one month before a presidential
effort to be re-elected
closest thing that ever happened to this
was 1956
dwight eisenhower was running for
re-election had an attack of ilioitis
intestinal problems he had to go to what
was then walter reed army hospital in a
different location
to get intestinal surgery and the way
that he dealt
with this was to say it's incumbent on
me to show the country
and the voters if you're just back my
computer uh
exploded and um i i'm slowly restarting
the stream and getting everything back
up and running we should be back up and
running shortly
as you can see things will start to uh
sort of repopulate here as the
as the term may be movements if you can
believe it
but that was what set the trend for
modern times when
presidents are pressed to be much more
open when they have a
life-threatening illness and i think if
you look through history
the presidents who have made mistakes
have been those who tried to be
secretive about their treatment and
about the details of their suffering
the ones who've done the best for
history and for the country
have been those who essentially said i'm
president i'm public property
you americans are entitled to know
everything you should
michael bachelos always appreciate your
perspective we want to go to holly
jackson again at the white house hallie
kind of walk us through you know where
we have journeyed since late last night
here in the east coast to this point
where the president is about to be
choppered to the hospital
boy lester what a journey it has been
you could even say late yesterday when
word first broke of that top eight hope
hicks testing positive for the
coronavirus that is what
sets some of these pieces in play
although we should note it is not clear
how the president contracted the
coronavirus it is not clear how long he
may have been contagious or not before
this positive test today
so let's talk about the timeline here
you can go back to saturday as we keep
an eye
i'm watching so i'm looking at the
screen here to see if the president
walks out
because we do expect that any minute
saturday night at the rose garden the
president held an event that's been
referenced here revealing his supreme
court nominee
two people there at least tested
positive for the coronavirus
monday and sunday the president had a
couple of events but tuesday is a
critical day because that is when he
traveled to the
debate in cleveland lester you and i
were on the air with the rest of our
team talking about that debate president
trump masculists on stage
with joe biden socially distanced and
the moderator as well but family members
in the audience
family members of the president unmasked
in the audience despite
requirements that that happen
essentially
the debate occurred the president was on
air force one with this entourage of
friends and family and advisors all
right guys i just turned chat back on
on youtube um it just glitched because
the stream restarted so we just refresh
and we're slowly getting everything back
together here these rallies the
president
is not wearing a mask many in the crowd
are not wearing masks there is virtually
no social distancing as well
do we imagine trump comes out of the
white house wearing a mask what do you
guys think
hicks condition she started to feel sick
and she quarantined on air force one
as the plane flew from minnesota back
here to washington that positive test
came up on thursday
and white house chief of staff mark
meadows told reporters here at the white
house today
the white house was aware of that
positive test as the president was
departing for a new jersey fundraiser as
he was lifting off actually marine one
24 hours ago yesterday that is when they
learned of hicks positive test now the
president still got on air force one and
traveled to that fundraiser
in bedminster new jersey returned home
took a test
went on fox news lester and revealed to
the to the world to the country
that he had taken a test and that he may
quarantine
until those test results came out and
then of course it was just before one
o'clock
this morning that's sort of where the
journey has taken us that the president
revealed that positive diagnosis
i think it's important the president is
often on okay so we are we oh okay the
twitter thing the president the most
he has not tweeted other than that tweet
uh so far today
and his appearance here on the white
house up on will be the first time that
we have seen him
that's right so for by the way for
people telling me youtube chat is still
off
it's not off i i see youtube chat and
super chats you've just gotta refresh
uh but it is youtube chat is back on
okay
let's get re-established here we were in
the middle of a great conversation and
just discussing a lot of the different
considerations that were going on here i
was thanking people
we were reading super chats andrew
bayhem for example pointing out that
trump hasn't tweeted in 16 hours
and listen we just don't know we will
presumably get a look at donald trump
momentarily
i don't think you will be able to notice
from his walk to the chopper
the true state of affairs i think that
this is going to be
stage managed so to speak so that this
looks as good as possible
trump really may have very mild symptoms
or it may be more serious we just don't
know
we just don't know uh and as bae photo
points out via super chat no
plan to transfer power to mike pence at
this time
if we learn that uh power has been
transferred to pence
um that will certainly be a sign that uh
that that things have gotten bad wayne
raya is new member number 11 today i do
want to thank wayne
as well as victoria pine who's new
member number 12.
k langenbacher is new member number 13.
anthony cockrell is number 14
and lucas jureska is new member number
15 today
i appreciate that and of course all of
the uh
all of the the same options for
supporting the streams
remain active as we await uh donald
trump's
move to walter reed medical center
with coronavirus bruce kesselring says
did you notice he called it covet 19 in
the tweet
and does that mean that he didn't write
it yeah that's um oh you know
several people noticed that donald
trump's last tweet
was uh at this point 16 hours ago ago
tonight flotus and i tested positive for
covid-19 yeah somebody else wrote it
that's not how trump writes but
often trump is dictating his tweets to
someone in the next room over anyway
so it's not again necessarily indicative
of anything we really just don't know
and we are going to see donald trump
here uh
momentarily expect at any second to head
to
um walter reed medical center via
marine one which is waiting on the lawn
of the white house for him
right now benjamin spiegel says forget
wearing a mask will he be watching or in
a stretch
walking or in a stretcher the white
house has already said that donald trump
is going to walk out
to the helicopter so
if indeed that happens we will see that
shortly
we will see that shortly um bryson
bernard whoa we are something's
happening with the camera here
bryson bernard says
david what are your thoughts on the
tapes of melania i have not
uh seen if they are there are new tapes
i've not read anything about it i've
been wrapped up
in this now i wonder did the white house
cut the feed
or is nbc merely recalibrating that
camera did the white house dig no okay
we're back
we're back okay joseph van scoy
says my first thought to this i wonder
how he's going to use this to his
advantage especially if he's largely
asymptotic no he's not this is not uh
this is not calculus
it's asymptomatic is the word not
asymptotic
i can imagine him using this as evidence
that covet is a conspiracy
yeah i think listen i i think trump
really has the virus
but i do think that if he gets past it
relatively quickly he will try to use it
to his advantage
absolutely we see a gathering of
officers near the door
through which donald trump is expected
to walk um
and we will uh we will keep an eye on
that
dad k says if pence is in power does he
debate biden
no i think that it's going to be harris
versus pence
on wednesday regardless unless
um pence has to do the job of president
in which case they will just cancel it
but pence isn't going to be the one
uh debating biden pence is not the
nominee remember
um so this is uh that that's that's the
way that is going to go
the proletariat notice uh noticed that
the president of notre dame university
tested positive for coronavirus i don't
know if that there's any connection here
to trump
on that but uh that is that is
interesting nonetheless
christopher hellstrom says if trump
isn't that sick do you think he's angry
by going to the hospital seeing it as
showing weakness listen
yeah if trump is going to the hospital
he's either
doing it under protest or because he's
really sick i think
trump of course is all about optics and
uh he would not be doing this unless he
was really being forced to or he thought
i'm sick i've really got to go um i
completely agree with that
um okay notre dame related to amy coney
barrett okay
uh i didn't realize that she was
recently there i thought she hadn't been
there for some time
i thought she had she spoke to notre
dame some uh some time ago
oh she's a professor oh so she's a judge
and a professor okay i didn't notice the
i didn't realize the professor thing
did not know she was actively a
professor
uh okay what else do we have going on
um ian fitzpatrick says a prior super
chat of mine listed typical hospital
course for covid
why did they jump to an experimental
treatment excellent question ian
we i don't know the answer we just i
don't know the answer
a bing says is this a play at
transferring power to pence and
pardons i really do not believe so
i do not believe so um for some reason
someone on twitch keeps asking me if i
trade on the stock market
i don't know the relevance of that right
now but um
i mostly own index funds where you pay
like five basis points
and i do have about eight or nine
individual stocks
and i've uh i i've mentioned what they
are
many times before
a crimson overture says what about the
senator that is also positive for covid
yeah i had
my computer restarted i had all of these
um let me see if i can i had all of
these clips ready for you guys
because um i take the stream seriously
and i try to have a bunch of stuff ready
there's video here of mike lee
uh i just don't know which one of these
it is let me see if i can find it
where is it
okay no that's not it where was it
there's video of mike lee
who was like hugging and kissing people
he's tested positive
oh i do have an interesting clip of
chris wallace
who just seems totally over what's going
on here listen to me i could say one
thing
to all of the people out there watching
forget the politics this is a public
safety health
issue the president of the united states
is the in the most secure bubble
in the world in the sense that everybody
who comes in contact with them has to
take a test
and he's still got it so wear the damn
mask
and follow the science that's the key
take away
can you oh my goodness oh oh wow
chris wallace said damn on fox news
uh guys you you've been propagating
disinformation about coronavirus for six
months now
you deserve someone to smack some sense
into you and if it's chris wallace who
has to do it then good for chris oh
oh my goodness he said damn oh my
goodness trump did a rally
with 4 000 people and no masks that's
the oh my goodness
they promote the rally oh my goodness
chris wallace said damn come on guys
they really deserve to be figuratively
smacked around
how dare he exactly give me a break
uh justin polidori asks
will melania be going to regardless of
her symptoms how about
moral support as far as we know right
now melania is not going
to uh to the hospital only trump
and you know who knows who else is going
to be there
with trump presumably some aides jacob
ducette says has anyone compiled the
list of prominent republicans and
democrats who have contracted kovid
would be fascinating to compare the
numbers
i haven't seen that um
okay let's take a listen to what lester
holt is saying
now we expect to see president trump
make his way we believe he will walk to
the chopper
and be taken to the walter reed national
military medical center in nearby
bethesda maryland
for what we're told is precautionary
treatment as we have been reporting he
was diagnosed
overnight with covet 19 both he
and the first lady the white house
describing both as suffering
mild symptoms nonetheless the president
going to be taken to the hospital
where he will have work facilities we're
told and that
they will be able to treat him perhaps
more effectively during the progress
of his disease uh dr lippy roy is an
internal
medicine physician and an nbc news
medical contributor she joins us now
doctor
so i'm getting um a number of people are
writing to me and sending me tweets that
it actually
the super spreader event that could have
been the catalyst for this could have
been the amy coney barrett
nomination event on saturday now there
are also reports that amy coney barrett
already had coronavirus
earlier in the summer there are then
counter reports
that it's believed she had it but she
never actually was tested that she just
had the symptoms and believed she had it
but didn't actually get a positive test
all of this is breaking right now and
i'm doing the best i can to keep up with
uh
with with everything um there is also
a report from jonathan martin
i'll just read this stuff to you guys
because we want to stay on screen here
and finding the tweets on the computer
will be tough
joe biden has announced that he's taking
down his negative ads about donald trump
in light of the diagnosis and is going
all positive
okay and also the decision to do that
was made
before so the decision was made after
trump was diagnosed but before
news that trump would be going to the
hospital so
biden saying they are not going to be
doing negative tests
i think it's all pretty stupid when it
comes to i mean listen
trump trump remains a horrifying leader
and
we have an election going on and
someone's going to be president for the
next four years
continuing to go after trump on policy i
think is
is fine but biden certainly just going
above and beyond
and saying he's going he's going to pull
uh negative ads
um there are a lot of right wingers
that i wanted to point out for example
this is matt walsh
on twitter saying i expected all the
leftists
gloating today i'm not scandalized or
outraged
instead i'm just exhausted from a
culture that produces such shitty human
beings
uh you know there there have been people
who have
said horrible things about biden and
hillary and obama
and there are people who are reacting to
this in a way that i don't think
is becoming uh but by and large
everybody's being respectful
so you know this is sort of a straw
manning concern trolling from the right
that they have absolutely no moral high
ground
uh to be coming from a couple of other
notes
for you a lot of people commenting on
this seeming incongruency between trump
being almost asymptomatic
to going to the hospital but again the
story being told
is it is merely out of an abundance of
caution
i do want to say thanks to colin buckley
as well as
natalie rozelle who are new members 16
and 17 today uh always appreciate
always appreciate folks who sign up at
joinpackman.com
we do have a discount code up there and
uh really appreciate everybody who
signed up in september
we were certainly buoyed in our
september by
uh the presidential debate which was a
really really big event for us
and uh on we go on we go to
october now the last month before the
election certainly with some
wrinkles thrown into it chris
asks how is he already showing symptoms
if he just tested positive
if he's showing symptoms already
shouldn't they have caught it beforehand
there are all sorts of apparent
uh you know inconsistencies with regard
to the timing particularly
of hope hicks getting tested and getting
the positive result
we just don't know we just don't know is
the reality
um thanks to funky kurt and
uh imb couscous who doesn't love
couscous
is couscous a pasta it is right couscous
is pasta isn't it
can we confirm couscous
pasta okay very good just making sure
uh very much appreciate that thanks to
joshua and sid
jabobster uh so many people goku that's
c-o-u-p
goku supporting over on twitch
um bing says
going to wr on our dime
wants to go going to walter reed on our
dime
wants to take our dimes and leave us no
health care
it looks like we are very very close to
donald trump exiting the white house we
now have
someone standing by here let's see what
we've got going on
taking this and reading this decision
to take the president to the hospital
though we are also told
that this was something that has been
under consideration in the works
since we learned that the president had
contracted the virus before
we necessarily understood that it was
perhaps serious enough for them to
consider
uh making this move okay guys i
apologize
now i'm understanding so or i just
mentioned
five minutes ago that it is thought that
the nomination event of amy coney
barrett
could have been the spreader event where
this started
the relevance of the president of notre
dame testing positive
is that the president of notre dame was
at that event
and that indeed is very relevant and
supports the idea
uh that that well could have been the
catalyst super spreader event
with which this started a frankfurter
asking whether i prefer chunky or smooth
peanut butter absolutely smooth
absolutely smooth
um you know i don't buy just we have a
very serious event but just to briefly
make a comment about peanut butter
i don't buy peanut butter spread
okay peanut butter spread you turn it
around you look at the ingredients
there's sugar there's salt
all sorts of additional elements
when i buy peanut butter i want one
ingredient and that is
unsalted peanuts that's peanut butter
anything else is candy
or a dessert okay now that being said
that being said some of these organic
peanut butters the oil separates
and i don't like that and the best
advice that i've gotten about that
is you flip it assume it before you even
open it you flip the can you flip the
jar
over the receptacle of peanut butter
over
and then you will deal with that
separation
of the peanut oil and it is whoa
camera going crazy again it has worked
really really well for me but if i were
to say
anything about peanut butter uh you want
one ingredient in peanut butter and that
is peanuts
and if you want salted okay so fine two
ingredients peanuts and salt
but if there's cane sugar in your peanut
butter if there's
honey in your peanut butter that's not
peanut butter
that is a sugar spread and i am against
it
i am against it very very much okay
uh apologies for people disgusted by
that rant but
it felt right it felt right
okay buffalo knives says asked before
your computer crashed jair bolsonaro and
boris johnson got
more popularity after being tested for
co testing positive for covid
you don't think trump will move any
points at all if he recovers i i think
he might no i think he might and i got
an interesting email today
from someone uh running analytics who
on news reports the stories about trump
have turned decidedly positive in nature
since his uh testing positive so that
certainly is the case
joseph van scoy says experimental
antibody treatment
is not something you would typically
give for an asymptomatic patient
that may be but most patients are also
not the president of the united states
so i don't uh i i don't know
big thank you to ryan honan for signing
up on my website
thanks to john clark for the
joinpacman.com membership
and thanks to cole smith you all are
new members number 18 19 and 20
today at joinpacman.com
also very much appreciate sally annette
for gifting five
subscriptions on uh twitch
uh matt avila says my peanut butter rant
that peanut butter rant was more
offensive than any joke about trump's
condition
thanks for the content david all right i
didn't know peanut butter was so
controversial
by the way don't even get me started
on jellies jams and preserves uh
that would be i think i would probably
lose my show
if i did that commentary
a collin says speculation but concerning
that he already has such symptoms when
the worst effects don't usually manifest
for at least a week
agree on the peanut butter again the the
official story is trump doesn't have
uh uh serious symptoms the official
story
is trump is trump is just going to
walter reed out of an abundance of
caution that's what we are being told
um oh people asking about my apple
preferences
listen i've said before the only apple i
want to eat
just as an apple is a granny smith i've
tried
dozens of other types of apples you know
maycon and empire golden delicious
um you know even the honey crisp if i'm
just having a plain apple
granny smith is the only way to go now
that being said over the weekend i did
go apple picking and
there were no granny smith i think
there's something about granny smith you
need
it's either different weather or it's a
different um time of the season this
isn't the time of the season in the
northeast where we have
granny smith i guess i picked other
types of apples i'll eat them but i only
want them in other
foods so i'm i've got an apple jelly
going upstairs i'm going to be making an
apple cake
i will be making apple sauce but for me
if i'm just eating an
apple it's granny smith that's it
that's it there's no sam cedar told me
about i'm gonna look up eric trump's
latest tweet sam cedar told me about
some apple
sam cedar is such a apple elitist
he told me about some apple available in
upstate new york
during like a seven day period in july
you know every tenth year or something
i'm exaggerating but
in any case uh it's like sam there's no
way i'm gonna get access to that apple
i'm sorry
it's just not happening leave me alone
with my granny smith
okay
okay this tweet from eric trump
is the first signal that this is more
serious than we're being told
eric trump just tweeted when we're told
trump is
barely symptomatic tru eric trump tweets
trump is a true warrior he will
fight through this with the same
strength and conviction that he uses to
fight for america each and every day
if you have a cold you don't usually get
that type of tweet although maybe eric
trump is being hyperbolic
i ask you to join me in praying for his
recovery
i've never been more proud of someone
and what they have had to endure
either that's hyperbolic or uh we are
not being told
the full scope of what is going on
um wow
okay that that is i don't even know what
to make of that
i don't even know what to make of that
let's see what is being discussed on
msnbc
it is a very mixed record news that is
to
the uh obscure and tending to the
misleading
in our past and i think that there's a
wonderful opportunity here
uh if the white house desired to take it
to be open to explain what's unfolding
uh more precisely in more detail
one of the lessons of good democratic
lower case d practice is that more
information
is often not only healthy for the life
of the nation
but has political benefits and
i remember as you do
that march day in 1981 when president
reagan was shot
the stories that came out were of this
remarkably resilient and brave american
president
who was joking with the doctors uh all
right
john meacham certainly not lost on him
the possibility
that this could be good politically for
trump but the concerns in the immediate
and again if you're just joining us eric
trump donald trump's
son um tweeting a message that
is not the type of message you typically
see
when someone has a cold and so this
suggests
that this is more serious than what we
are being told
i am now being directed sue to a c-span
tweet
by our beautiful twitter viewers i'm
sorry twitch viewers
let me see what c-span has tweeted
um they tweeted uh a note from the
president's doctor from an hour ago i'm
not seeing anything else
um i don't know if i'm missing it but
if i'm supposed to be looking at
something else they also tweeted about a
kamala harris event later on today
let me see yeah we already went over i'm
not seeing anything here that's
that's new that we haven't covered
already
um but certainly feel free to you know
keep me apprised of other things we
should be looking at
okay other super chats coming in
american citizen is still skeptical
american citizen says i find it
difficult to believe he has coveted
this october surprise he will come back
the october surprise he will come back
healthy as ever in a few days espousing
a magical cure i really don't think so
i really don't think so i i don't think
that that's what this is
um i i think it's certainly possible
that he will recover because he's
getting some treatment most people don't
have access to
but i i belie i think the risks are too
obvious uh too unpredictably obvious too
obviously unpredictable may be better
said
to fake having coronavirus i just don't
see it guys i don't see it
i want to say thanks to jimmy galletti
jimmy galletti is new member number 21
today
at joinpakman.com i do really appreciate
your support
um multibeast has subscribed with twitch
prime and says
crisp apple is the best apple listening
since the midweek politics days
i've had honey crisp i don't really get
it and you know what's really sad is
when i went apple picking over the
weekend
honey crisp is basically like marketing
honey crisp
the honey crisp trees were bare there
was not a single honeycrisp apple left
on the trees if i wanted honeycrisp i
was gonna have to pick up
smashed apples from the ground which i
didn't do
i i just don't i just don't get uh i
don't get the appeal
of honeycrisp quite frankly michael says
who gets oh
we lost it hold on where'd that go
let me find that who who gets trump's
debt if he passes
melania or one or all of his kids
also the karma from how or who he got it
huh should have waited like obama and
merrick
i i don't believe that at all i think
that's crazy um
i think you know the debts how do the
debts go because you can leave
assets in your will um
i think what happens is the debt sort of
st you'd have to talk to an estate
attorney but i think the assets stay
with
the the debts stay with trump but the
creditors go
after the heirs so i think the cr you
know deutsche bank would be knocking on
eric trump's uh
door presumably
um okay cynthia mccracken
says this means trump's preventative
hydroxychloroquine is ineffective lol
well no trump took the preventative
hydroxy months ago
he would have to uh he would have to
keep taking it
in order for it to uh to continue
continue doing its work
um people are asking me what do i think
about twitter banning people hoping
trump dies
you know listen i i would be a hypocrite
if i said there was anything wrong with
twitter doing it when twitter has
decided we don't allow deliberate
misgendering on our platform that's
bullying
that's twitter's call and if twitter
says we're not going to allow
you know people wishing for trump's
death on the platform i'm fine with it
would i do that i don't know um i think
it's it's a bad look
i don't think it's a good idea to be
wishing for trump's death
uh if twitter you know followed its
terms and conditions
trump would have been banned for
bullying a while ago but
it's certainly fine for twitter to do
that
uh okay daniel rivera oh no
daniel is unsubscribing because of my
intolerant
peanut butter comments that's sad
a frankfurter says i know you're
covering something more serious but how
does one get
actual peanut butter and not sugar
spread
i i mean you get it at the grocery store
i don't know if that's a trick
question uh-oh the photographer getting
into position here
um you just look like for example when
you go to
if you go to trader joe's as an example
or whole foods or wherever
you'll see that there's not just crunchy
you you would think that if there were
just peanut butters there's four
right you've got crunchy salted and
crunchy unsalted smooth salted and
smooth unsalted
but you have a bunch and oftentimes
spread is in really little letters
like it'll say peanut butter spread
you just got to look at the ingredients
this is not uh this is not rocket
science my friends
um arun mehta says boris got a boost
but went south because of brexit labor's
keith uh keir starner considered
prime minister in waiting daniel bergman
says couscous is not pasta parkman come
on
it's not a grain is
couscous pasta couscous is pasta come on
guys it's pasta it's made of wheat or
barley
uh i guess technically barley couscous
barley couscous is not pasta i think i'm
going to say
but but you know wheat flour
semolina flour couscous that's a pasta
that's a pasta brody andrew mulligan
says please consider preparing a voter
guide
for down ballot progressives heading
into the general election
we need to make sure we need to make
sure we get them the green new deal
uh my phone is absolutely exploding
i think people are are just trying to
get me information about
different news that's breaking about
this um
oh my god everything is exploding let's
see i want to make sure everybody gets
all of the right information joe biden
tweeting this cannot be a partisan
moment
it must be an american moment we have to
come together as a nation
a lot of reports of course from an hour
ago that donald trump is going to the
hospital
we do see movement here and people oh it
looks like he's coming out of a
different door
guys it looks like he's not coming out
of the store he may be walking now
and being blocked by the chopper let's
see you might have gotten a glimpse
there
of the president uh but who made his way
on his own
and i'm assuming we will get the the
videotape turn around
of those pictures from the other side of
the helicopter but
the president we believe has just
boarded uh they blocked air force one
uh he's got some staff with him we don't
know if the first lady
is traveling with him uh but it'll be a
very
very
short flight over to bethesda and the
walter reed national military medical
center where he will
be offered precautions now as he deals
with this diagnosis of covet 19
apparently feeling mild symptoms and
he's been treated
at the white house itself but doctors
thought it was advisable to transfer him
to the hospital hallie jackson uh also
uh
watching along with us uh uh hallie uh
we see many a time of course the
president stop at the rope line you guys
fire questions
uh at him uh would he have had to pass
that rope line to get where he is
if he had walked out the way he
typically does then yes lester and as
has been talking about we're looking at
a bit of a reverse angle than we're used
to seeing you were right in that we are
expecting to see
what we call in our tv parlance the tape
playback so we should be able to see
that shot of president trump boarding
marine one
i'm told by our pool reporter colleagues
the small team of reporters who
represent the rest of the pool that
he walked out in a mask and suit walked
to the chopper
to marine one followed by white house
chief of staff mark meadows
no sign of first lady melania trump so
perhaps an indication that she is
remaining back
isolating at the residence there okay
lester this is unusual in so many ways
but let me tell you one way
that it is very unusual and that is that
the president was in a mask that is not
something that we have seen from him
often it is in fact extremely rare
as i can hear now on the north lawn uh
the rotors start to pick up speed it
looks as though marine one will lift off
any second when that happens
uh those reporters are able to sort of
run that tape physically back into the
white house and then we'll be able to
see that video lester but
clearly the white house by placing these
cameras and putting reporters out here
to see the president
wanted to show him uh up and walking
around and getting on marine one and
and sort of have an appearance by the
president to hopefully in their view
put people's minds at ease about his
condition they have been talking about
what they say
are mild symptoms from president trump
as we can hear
hopefully you can't hear it on my
microphone but the marine one rotor
getting louder and louder here yeah we
can uh
we in fact can see it hallie from our
our camera angle here the uh
helicopter rotor is now spinning and
should be lifting offshore you know one
of the things that suggests it is true
that this is mild is that the choppers
but we've been watching the chopper sit
there for an hour if this really were
more urgent you would imagine they would
have gotten it moving more quickly that
is that is a thought
obviously by uh medical staff who will
be wearing
i'm sure full protective gear as we've
seen in so many hospitals over the last
uh
seven eight months uh here during this
pandemic but uh the
president about to depart uh the white
house uh what a day of dramatic
developments
hey guys yeah in the chat you know
anything about
helicopter crashes trump dying
moderators are fully deputized to drop
the ban hammer
uh we we're not we have not yet run out
of memberships and we are not going to
run out of bans just letting everybody
know we're not we're not participating
in that stuff here
from the white house grounds
a uh a unique moment
to be following american politics
without a doubt
without a doubt
i believe it's only a seven or so minute
ride i believe to walter reed something
like that
we're soon going to get the video of
trump actually walking out
wearing a mask unclear if we will get
video of the arrival at walter reed
[Music]
if you're just joining us donald trump
after testing positive for coronaviruses
being brought to walter reed medical
center
where he's expected to remain for days
in fact and
uh will reportedly be working
from walters setting sun gliding off the
side of marine one as he pivots away
from the white house for the
short flight to bethesda and the walter
reed national military medical center
incredible sight to see and again
incredible incredible uh
series of developments that have brought
us to this point a president who there
is uh
why is it sped up admittedly uh well
here i'm sorry this is the tape now
it's been sped up why is it sped up
what on earth
all right you can see so that video was
sped up but that's a very quick
turnaround of the video we saw the
president getting
on maybe soon we'll be able to see it in
sort of uh normal
normal normal time um
let's see here
um people angry about the peanut butter
take
and just a lot of different things being
said
connor says david it's amazing how you
can be so ethical towards trump and yet
so hateful and divisive about apples
yeah well you know the apples don't have
feelings that i'm aware of
more than two dozen hot spot states uh
in this country now seeing an
increase in cases uh but certainly uh
covet has a different and a new face
tonight
in that of the president of the united
states let's go to peter alexander
uh peter is at the white house uh you
had a look at those pictures as well
uh that was the standard way the
president would normally uh board the
chopper
yeah lester you're right and as we look
at the helicopter now flying to
walter reed medical center um you're
looking at the most
prominent patient in the planet
president trump now among
millions of people across the globe who
have suffered from this
this awful infection of coronavirus
covid
19 just moments ago as you noted we did
see and we will play it for you in real
time just moments from now the president
departing the residence notably he was
dressed in a suit as he traditionally is
you almost never see him
in casual attire except perhaps on a
weekend excursion to play golf always
dressed
in a full suit with a tie clearly the
intention by this white house is to show
that this president
remains at work as we've discussed he
was wearing a mask
he was trailed only a short distance
behind by his chief of staff mark
meadows
who was also wearing a mask here today
and so for the next several days the
president
will now convalesce at walter reed
medical center where white house
officials insist he will continue to do
his work
communicating with top lawmakers over
the course of the day and
including the senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell today mcdonald's saying
that their conversation
focused on among other things their
desire to confirm
judge amy coney barrett against the
intention to communicate to the american
people
that this president remains on the job
white house officials telling us only a
short time ago
that president trump is in charge here
now
lester you can see on the right side of
your screen the picture just moments ago
the president
with a thumbs up a wave walking slowly
from the residents of south portico
i mean do does it really make sense to
go to the hospital for days
if he's if he's fine i i just don't know
i don't know i understand it's the
president i understand
boris johnson went to a hospital but
boris johnson was reportedly quite sick
was he not i think that
nobody was saying boris johnson was fine
offering a triple tap there as you saw
on the railing as he
stepped aboard the helicopter to take
his seat and on the left side of your
screen that's the live picture
we don't think the helicopter will be
out of our view much because it's only
about a 10 mile
flight from the white house to bethesda
as we noted there is a
military landing
helicopter for the chopper there so
all right so we will follow it um uh we
we will follow it all the way
over to uh walter reed medical center
there in bethesda
maryland and um what what just
we don't know what to make we don't know
what to expect we don't know what now
happens to this election we don't know
what happens
uh to the country we don't know what
happens with the pandemic and we don't
know what happens to the president
we really just don't know any of these
things now and of course when you have
an administration that's been so
extraordinarily dishonest all the time
it would be natural it is natural to
question
everything everything that we are being
told i want to say thanks to jojo green
for signing up at joinpakman.com jojo
your new member number 22.
carrie wallace's new member number 23
taylor
fontechio is new member number 24
and i really i really appreciate your
support
uh now as is typical i believe that you
have
multiple helicopters joining uh for
decoy purposes
and expecting the arrival at walter reed
medical center
any second let's listen duty of
government um the president's health
making sure that
we're we're getting all of the uh
all of the um truth that we can out of
the white house i will say this
uh it it you know him being upright
walking under his own power
climbing up the stairs you know that
does seem to at least comport
with the white house talking point of
saying that he's just going there
out of an abundance of caution so you
know that's why these appearances do
matter is that you know it's one thing
for the white house to tell us
no no no this is doing an abundance of
precaution but to see him
let people make up their own mind um and
to see what they're seeing today but
look this is
clearly you know this is a uh
this is real life and this pandemic uh
having a
impacting um our continuity of
government
and this campaign and it's something
that we have all known was going to be
inevitable that
no matter how much you try uh to put
this virus in the rearview mirror this
virus
uh so for people asking about the sort
of succession line
correct me if i'm wrong guys i mean we
could look this up but why it's more fun
to maybe be wrong
it would go to mike pence then it's
speaker of the house nancy pelosi
i believe after that it would be senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell
and then after that who's after mitch
mcconnell does it go to treasury
secretary
oh it's grassley oh it's gr why is it oh
it's the senate pro temp
okay senate pro temp right okay
and then after that it is uh after that
it's mnuchin i believe right does it go
is it treasury secretary
uh here is donald trump arriving at
walter reed medical center
inside this military installation
earlier today
are in a position to get pictures of
marine one landing the president
getting off the chopper and then
presumably going into the hospital
so we will have those images as well
here on the street
traffic certainly stopped there's been a
greater police presence
here as people have been watching this
unfold a lot of
pedestrians have come here um most of
them if not all are wearing masks
there's very high
mask wearing here of course hey you know
if nothing else
people are going to wear the masks now
aren't they i mean it's like the people
not wearing them were mostly trumpets
this is going to increase mass wearing
dramatically you would imagine yeah i
know a lot of them
won't but many will wouldn't they
president now being
treated for coronavirus multiple days
here as a hospital patient expected
inside a facility that has a long eight
year history of treating presidents
and military brass and patients of a
bra of a wide variety but no one more
significant in terms of the government
and the continuity and all those other
issues you've talked about
than a president who is now one of the
many
americans who has coronavirus with
enough symptoms and enough concern
that he's going to get medical treatment
here we've talked about the special
suite
that's involved inside the the walter
reed facilities
which is certainly a very significant
full floor of available square footage
for the president his team and the white
house
that'll effectively be operating the
government pilots wearing masks listen
everybody's wearing masks now
although still reports that they will
not be mandatory within the white house
but we will see care is dr sean connelly
who is the white house physician
remaining in charge or will there be a
new attending physician
who is a part of the structure here at
the hospital those are questions we'll
have certainly going forward
and we'll have to see how forthcoming
the white house and walter reed
will be in providing that additional
information but there is certainly
a very notable patient who's about to be
admitted here at walter reed national
military medical center lester
down comes the door you can see the crew
has uh turned off the engines marine
now lowering the stairs and we will
expect again to see the president
i'm being uh told now that the white
house has changed its mind and that as
of about 20 minutes ago masks
will be mandatory uh the front and back
steps of marine one opening
and uh a full convoy of vehicles now
arriving as well
we will see whether donald trump walks
to wherever he is going or is brought
by car
there's mark meadows on the back stairs
i believe that's mark meadows
there is donald trump talking like mark
meadows is chief of staff
standing at the doorway and there's the
president
wearing the mask now that's for sure
the president lost from our side of this
camera there
but it looks like he will uh he will be
driven to another entrance of the
hospital the full motorcade in place
there
but important uh for americans and for
the world to see the american president
on his own two feet and seeking
precautionary treatment i think is how
it's being put
here at the military hospital
again the uh the white house has said he
has had uh
minor symptoms related to covet 19.
full n95s apparently for
everybody in the vehicle and around
trump it has very quickly gotten
very real and uh uh we we are now seeing
donald trump
moved from the helicopter
to some entrance at walter reed
depending on the journey of this
particular disease
as we watch this let me go back to uh
hallie jackson
hallie what is that what has it been
like at the white house
it's demanding you look at the abc
coverage of course the day has been
treated
with regeneron and is expected to but
this isn't even allowed to read
medical center for more tests let's go
to our chief white house course
see if we can find it here's five years
hope it's really become
part of the trump family as well oh it's
georgie oh no doubt short she's
the adopted child of the trump family
the president himself
uh often refers to her as hopi um and
then someone
you know for so long has been in tow
with the first family her office
up until she departed the white house in
2018
was the closest one to the oval office
just outside
the president's door and when she
returned this year many aides in the
west wing and
family members of the president
as someone that had the president's
trust loyalty
we've got to see this trump put up a
video let's see what this is about
i want to thank everybody for the
tremendous support
okay hold on hold on let me get us some
more volume because this we have to hear
hold on a second
i want to thank everybody for the
tremendous support
i'm going to walter reed hospital i
think i'm doing very well
but we're going to make sure that things
work out the first lady is doing very
well so thank you very much i appreciate
it i will never forget it thank you
all right so donald trump there uh
continuing to insist that he's
essentially
fine that he is essentially fine
and we will continue to monitor that
um and see what it is that is going on
big thank you to john blouth for
subscribing on my website
christy paul jonathan garver
daniel hold on a second daniel
schweinbeck as well as adam pellick
who are new members 25 26 27
28 and 29. let me see what else is on
people's minds
connor says honestly david the ignorance
i see in arizona regarding
masks and social distancing leads me to
not have much hope
largely dependent on his attitude later
we will see
um maria
lihare says german here i am very torn i
believe he is sick
but there's always that small doubt
isn't that horrible that we can't
believe
anything the white house says it is
something else
it is it is truly something else that we
we doubt even this because they are so
dishonest
uh there perhaps is nobody more close
to melania than her her elderly parents
and she has actually been caring for her
mother who was sick
so you know there's a lot of concern for
a very very close family the closest
people on earth to melania trump and she
eats dinner and lunch and
breakfast you okay
i think we i think we lost mary jordan
there uh
again let me bring uh let me bring
matthew dowd back in
lost maria jordan let's see what nbc has
likely that the president is still going
to have to isolate
if he does end up coming back here to
the white house after a few days and
that is because of the cdc guidelines
when it comes to somebody who has tested
positive for coronavirus for somebody
who is showing symptoms of coronavirus
the the isolation period is 10 days
after the onset of symptoms
if they start improving and 24 hours
fever-free so those are the thresholds
the parameters that likely if the white
house is following cdc guidelines
the president would have to end up
following as long along with the first
lady in order to be sort of out of that
isolation period lester
we know the vice president pence that
makes it extraordinary
extraordinarily unlikely that we get a
debate in 13 days uh i guess now yeah 13
days from today
uh really close to 12 because it's
getting late now here on the east coast
um i i don't see how we have debate
number two
i do want to say thank you to oceanova
for gifting five subscriptions on twitch
as well as david chadman
david chadman who's my brother
gave out 10 subscriptions
10 subscriptions over on twitch oceanova
also has now been subscribed for 15
months
i don't even know how that's possible
because i've only been on twitch for 14
months
but somehow oceanova has figured out a
way to do it and says i'm the og
we can always count on your presence and
contemplative analysis
you are oceanova i don't know of anybody
else who's been subscribed 15 months
uh on on twitch that appears to be uh
com
completely and totally accurate a little
awkward to talk politics right now
because his health obviously most
important
but he is a competitor is there any
speculation or talk that he may try to
do virtual
events during his coding lessons so we
don't know for sure what the president
will do but the campaign
hopes to and intends to do virtual
events based on a statement from them
earlier today some events will be
postponed
some will be virtual and you have to
remember lester that this is a president
and i covered him in 2016 at rally after
rally i've covered him throughout his
time in the administration
he loves being on the road for months
for months i have been hearing from
people close to the campaign and close
to the white house
about how eager the president was to
pick up the pace of his on the road
campaigning to get out of the white
house
as we get closer and closer to election
day we are now 32 days out from election
day
and rather than being on the road the
president is is
just the opposite of that he is
isolating he is in the hospital and then
will likely end up returning to the
white house if in fact it is
that time period i'll hold a second on
that hallie because the uh the president
has apparently just posted a video of
himself i haven't seen it but we got it
already
i want to thank everybody for the
tremendous support
i'm going to walter reed hospital i
think i'm doing very well
but we're going to make sure that things
work out the first lady is doing very
well
so thank you very much i appreciate it i
will never forget it thank you
so halle a small thing a video a small
thing of watching somebody born
we are all caught up now donald trump
and melania trump
testing positive very late last night
early this morning donald trump now
flown via helicopter
to walter reed medical center where he's
expected to be for several days for what
the white house continues to say are
mild symptoms donald trump certainly
looked okay there
walking to the helicopter i do not
expect that we are going to have
anything particularly breaking in the
next several
hours i wanted to hop on see what was on
your minds
and we we happen to see the transfer to
walter reed
but that's going to do it for me today
certainly
i'm not going anywhere i will be around
during the weekend i will hop back on
should news break otherwise i will see
everybody
on monday thanks for joining me
you